[Music]
hello i'm linda you a warm welcome to
this institute of art and ideas live
event it's my pleasure to host this
debate democracy a failing strategy
worldwide 36 million people took part in
demonstrations against western
intervention in the middle east now
biden has granted their wish the tide of
opinion has turned from withdrawing
troops or fighting clover to managing
the economy and tackling the refugee
crisis we are used to hearing that the
public is polarized but now a troubling
new trend is becoming clear not only do
voters disagree with one another they
can quickly change their minds and
disagree with themselves
so can the people really be trusted is
the idea of delivering the will of the
people an impossible dream when
individual desires are so changeable
is democracy losing its crown as the
least worst option
or are the alternatives still far worse
to debate this let me introduce this
terrific panel jasmine alibaba brown is
a journalist and author she has met and
advised politicians peers and ministers
including prime minister david cameron
on diversity and inclusion policies in
britain's complex democracy alice
guerrero is a professor of philosophy at
rutgers university and current editor
chief of philosophy camp compass he has
argued for lottocracy which he will tell
us about which proposes that leaders
should be appointed by lottery rather
than by election tom brake is a former
politician for the liberal democrats and
mp from 1997 to 2019 he was appointed
director of the cross party pressure
group unlock democracy in october of
last year
and they campaigned for greater
participatory democracy in the uk kaizu
zhang is professor of law at yale
university he's also a comparative
historian legal theorist and occasional
commentator on china he is author of the
laws and economics of confucianism which
received the 2018 gaddy smith book prize
so now let's kick off with the
three-minute position from each panelist
on the pitch question
can democracy ever truly deliver the
will of the people
alex
so
this question
about delivering the will of the people
uh i initially you know as a philosophy
got to question the question so
i'm suspicious that there is something
the will of the people or that that's
what democracy is about or that somehow
that's what we should be aiming at uh
two reasons for suspicion
one i think often we don't have an
opinion as individuals about a lot of
the political problems that we face we
don't know about the issues and so there
isn't some opinion that we just need to
somehow aggregate or collect we need to
form our views about these things and we
need to do that in light of what other
people think about them so i see it not
so much as you know tracking the will of
the people or realizing it but in some
cases really creating it through
discussion and other processes
another thing that the will of the
people framing suggests is that there's
some you know voice that we all share
that we can all speak with but i think
in most modern democracies you see deep
foundational disagreement about almost
everything and so rather than thinking
we just need to unearth the will of the
people and make sure we're acting in
line with that i think often what we're
trying to do or should be trying to do
is figure out how is it that we can
balance this disagreement and diversity
of opinion and how can we come to live
together so what i think we should be
measuring when we look at is democracy
performing well
isn't is it sort of delivering the will
of the people but more is it helping us
to solve the political problems that we
actually face rather than imagined or
manufactured ones and so i think we need
to be able to identify what those
problems are when political systems can
work well to help us do that and so
what's great about democracy when it's
working well is that it's an effective
form of government it's solving our
problems the people's problems and doing
that both effectively but also doing it
in a responsive way so that it's
reacting to each of our views about
these things as we develop those views
thanks
thank you alex
tai soo thung
um i share a lot of alex's concerns um i
like
at any given time i i'm dubious as to
whether there is
such a thing as the world of people that
you can actually measure and identify
um for all the reasons that alex
describes plus i'm also
honestly rather pessimistic about the
political salience of most issues to
most people
and also about the willingness of most
people in any given society to devote
these the sufficient amount of time and
energy to any given issue to actually
form something resembling
an intelligible and consistent um
opinion
um that said like
so so legal theorists and political
theorists have all have always
distinguished between like kind of like
random moods of
the populace
and moments where their moods
crystallize into something that's more
defined and more politically actionable
right so
uh one of my colleagues bruce zuckerman
has a tendency to call the call those
moments constitutional moments
and the theory being that there are some
some some periods of time some
extremely silly political issues
upon which actual political mobilization
of the populace is possible and it is an
issuance of a clear voice from the
population through a democratic process
uh actually can be done
um so my view of democracy as it's
performed over the past half century or
century or so
has certainly been like when you come
into those moments and those moments are
not common but they're they're
they're they're quite rare but they do
exist when you come into those moments
most um let's just say basically
functional product blockers they're not
captured by like an autocratic straw man
do a reasonably good job of expressing
that crystallized
sentiment
like that kind of crystallized
commitment um the problem with democracy
is they also do a help a lot more than
just that like
times in which there is no definitive
will expressed by the people when what's
really being expressed is a set of
incoherence on mutually contributing
moods
by the populists well democracy also has
a has a way of flattening those those
those contradictions
into what seems like a simple political
message and then acting upon that
um and then
that often becomes problematic in all
kinds of ways so i think that you know
what insofar as there can be a wolf to
people up here
at some point in time yes democracies
can reflect that um they usually do a
pretty good job of doing so the problem
is they also reflect much more than just
the role of the people and that tends to
be their their i guess effectiveness
problem
thank you now moving across the atlantic
away from the east coast of the united
states and uh to the uk let me bring in
tom brady
thank you very much linda for having me
for this event
and um can i just start by by looking
perhaps at two periods in time uh going
back to the 1970s in the uk the 1970s
there were lots of things that people
will be quite familiar with that are
happening at the moment in terms of cues
at petrol stations
shortages on the shelves and no doubt
soon
uh significant inflation in the uk
and i think that that's that was perhaps
one of those moments in time or periods
in time that taisu was talking about in
uk politics where
it was a period of turmoil and people
reached a conclusion that they wanted
something to happen
now i was not and and had never been a
supporter of margaret thatcher and in
fact she is the person who got me into
liberal politics but i don't think
anyone could argue that she didn't act
on the will of the people
in terms of
uh
overhauling industry
looking at the role of trade unions
extending property ownership so she took
action she responded i think to the will
of the people
moving forward to what has happened in
the last five years in the uk over
brexit
again i think one could argue that uh
notwithstanding all of the risks
associated with it which were
highlighted by
economists through to
probably the majority of cabinet
ministers
the prime minister boris johnson has got
brexit done of sorts
and has delivered the will of the people
but i think what we need to do with our
democracy is see it evolve it needs to
be much subtler
and i suspect on this alex will be very
much in agreement with me that what we
need to see
is a participle participative process
things like citizens assemblies in which
the public can debate issues can hear
from the much maligned
experts that michael gove referred to
and come to a more considered
position or decision in relation to some
of the most critical issues
that faces and we know that the evidence
is that people will come to
well-informed balanced decisions in
those circumstances so i just like to to
finish with george monbio's words
which are that what we need to do is we
need to blend representative democracy
with participative democracy because
that is what i think is the future of
our democracy
thank you tom
yasmin alibi brown
thank you let me let me start with a
little personal thing
i had no i grew up without any
democratic rights until i was 23 years
old
because i grew up in a british i was
born into a british colony in uganda and
then we had a brief moment of
independence and a kind of working
democracy for i think 18 months
and then a military dictatorship
facilitated by the usc and the uk and
therefore my arrival in in this to this
country
i discovered
that such a thing as democratic votes
existed so when the brits talk about
importing
exporting democracy they never did that
point number one so i really value it
and i fear that as it is still
the the least worst
method
i do not care for the expression
will of the people i think we should use
a much more accurate term
will of most of the people
because i think once you start
banging on about will of the people even
during
tom was talking about the 70s i came
here
exactly at that point
when the country was in in a mess and
then this strong lady leadership came
through but actually
if you say it was the will of the people
it wasn't the will of the miners it
wasn't the will of working-class people
in trade unions so if we said the real
will of most people which is what
happened with brexit
right
now i think our democracy here is
severely degraded and so does the index
on democracy actually
it can very easily happen india has
is now a much more degraded uh democracy
than it once was
and i think the reasons for that is that
democracy has become a kind of ladder on
which very authoritarian fighting moral
leaders and i in my view we have a
deeply moral leader at the moment
can get
the legitimacy
to behave in really quite
extraordinarily undemocratic ways
because all the pillars the judiciary
checks and balances independence of the
civil service
freedom of um the press we have freedom
of the press we also have a very
unbalanced press
um
has created has given him more authority
and power than any other leader we have
had in recent years even blair okay and
so i think we are in in danger of having
democracy
uh being used by quite an authoritarian
and charming figure
you know a very problematic combination
of actually thwarting some of the
central pillars of democracy i agree
with tom that there has to be another
way and i agree with
the the george monbiot um
way forward
but we are now living in an increasingly
authoritarian state
a corrupt state
so i i think we really need
the ngo sector civil society
real democrats need to kind of
come together to see what we can do to
stop this degradation and power grab
parliament's has become the will of bill
boris johnson that's not democracy
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas